president biden has not had much luck
lately inflation at record highs gas
prices also at record highs a migrant
surge at the border a crime surge within
the borders the first major war in
europe in 70 years approval ratings in
the doldrums and the progressive loss of
his ability to form coherent english
sentences
but yesterday
biden finally may have received a sign
that his luck is about to turn around
when a bird defecated on his blazer
at the center of our efforts to build a
future that's made in america
and that's not hyperbole it's about
being made in america
a lot of that has to do with this and
there it is there you can see it he's
talking and then this little white kind
of appears and we know what happened a
bird
defecated on him the notion that a bird
defecating on you constitutes good luck
is an old russian superstition based on
the sheer improbability of it happening
experts have put the odds at around 0.18
that's that's the the regression the
analysis has shown that it's that small
but it's not true
for everyone if you live in new york
city the odds increase to about 1.14
percent since new york is home to more
than one million pigeons and both of
those numbers are based on an average
person spending 5184 seconds per day
outside exposed to the predations of
bird bowels if you increase the number
of pigeons in your city or if you
increase the time you spent exposed to
birds your chances would increase even
more if for instance you locked yourself
in a room filled to the brim with birds
and gave yourself nowhere to hide your
odds of getting crapped on by a bird
would be 100
which is why
i don't think joe biden's bad luck is
going to turn around
because joe biden's bad luck has not
been based on random chance
inflation is up in part because biden
and his party have printed and spent
money with reckless abandon and in part
because gas is increasing as well which
occurred because joe biden stifled
american oil production shut down a new
american oil pipeline and then gave a
new pipeline to vladimir putin which in
turn gave putin the opportunity to
invade ukraine which is causing oil to
spike even more causing massive domestic
instability which biden is exacerbating
by encouraging an historic flood of
illegal aliens pouring over the southern
border by refusing to enforce the law
which in turn biden and democrats are
also flouting throughout the rest of the
country by defunding the police and
letting criminals off the hook which in
turn is causing an historic wave of
crime that is now entering its third
year in other words
biden has made his own bad luck and it's
going to take a lot more than avian
excrement to turn it around i'm michael
knowles it's the michael show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday comes from
fukushima rose what a name my fukushima
rose the glowingest flower that grows i
became a daily wire member over the
weekend one reason in particular was to
watch fauci unmasked i give the
documentary an a minus
only because michael never did his
fouchy impression outstanding job thank
you very much fukushima rose i
appreciate your compliment i certainly
hope that other people come and watch it
as well
because
if you don't believe it yet i hope the
last few days have shown you
dr fauci
is coming back
kovit it's come it's all coming back
folks the libs are just waiting on it
but they're holding on to that power
okay and as all the other political
issues get worse as they do worse in the
polls for the midterms you're going to
see that come right up
one of the big issues for them is
inflation specifically
inflation with regard to food which is
why you got to check out good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com
knowles most people listening to this
show right now have never in their
entire lifetimes seen inflation like we
are seeing right now and that inflation
is particularly pronounced when it comes
to food what if i told you you can
inflation proof your food purchases
right now forever and i'm specifically
talking about the most important
delicious food you put on the table i'm
talking about beef and better than
organic chicken too but i'm more
concerned with that steak with those
burgers with that ground beef you can
subscribe right now to good ranchers
they already have ridiculously low
prices for fabulous quality meat
amazing american beef and meat from from
american ranches and you just get locked
into that price forever and you get
another 30 discount on top of that
for their prime steaks for their better
than organic chicken the way to do it
it's not too good to be true this is for
our listeners go to goodranchers.com
knowles to save on the quality you've
been looking for good ranchers takes all
the guesswork out of the grocery store
sources everything locally use code
knowles kennedywles
on your box of 100 american meat and you
will get your 30 savings i suggest you
subscribe you can also buy the boxes one
off to give it a try order now to combat
inflation with good ranchers american
meat delivered
joe biden was defecated on
while he was giving a speech in iowa
about inflation
frankly the part where the bird relieved
itself on biden's shoulder was one of
the more coherent parts of the speech
the rest of the speech sounded like this
i was iva's campaign here and i made
that commitment
i don't think anybody heard it but we're
back
we're back and i uh
my name is joe joe biden i work for
congressman axne
there she is
i learned a long time ago when she says
i have a i just say yes
i say yes right off the bat
so and frankly even that rambling
nonsense was more coherent than a lot of
the rest of the speech here obviously
here biden is trying to tell jokes
this has been biden's whole career he
doesn't really have anything to say he
doesn't really have any political vision
whatever political vision he had he's
contradicted many times because he's an
empty suit politician he's a glad hander
who just licks his finger and figures
out which way the wind is blowing
some politicians actually do have
ideological views and really pursue them
biden isn't one of them so he's always
gotten by on jokes and smiling and slap
you on the back but he can't even tell
the jokes anymore uh mine he kind of
forgets where he is he looks down on the
paper uh i'm joe biden
and i i work for the congressman
and but he's not delivering them well so
he's got nothing so he's stammering
around people are trying to politely
sort of chuckle then he starts babbling
about
chickens in delaware
we have a four billion dollar industry
it's called agriculture in delaware and
it's mostly we have more chickens in
delaware broilers chickens than you have
in the entire midwest i think but all
kids aside it is a big industry in
delaware
all kidding aside but it it
it doesn't work
joe biden's
usual mo his usual political strategy of
just kind of telling jokes and getting
by and smiling doesn't work because he
he is not forming english sentences
properly
either the man is drunk before he gives
every speech or he's senile it's the
only way to explain how he's slurring
his words and missing his cadence and
screwing up the syntax they're going to
try to blame it on a childhood stutter
that he had 70 years ago allegedly that
just disappeared magically for what 65
70 years and then it came roaring back
when biden turned 78 years old
it's i don't think that's very
believable or
or he's drunk which i don't think he is
or he's senile
in any event
the latter is probably the most
worrisome at least if he were drunk he
could go to rehab for a week and come
back and actually run the country but he
can't he's senile and that's why
everything is falling to pot not just on
the domestic front but notably on
foreign policy as well because america's
enemies look at him and they say okay
america's weak they've got no one
running the show and so we're going to
we're going to do what we want to do and
you see russia expanding now into
ukraine russia's war in ukraine has now
prompted julian lennon
julian lennon is the first son of john
lennon to to break a rule that he had
made for himself julian lennon said many
years ago that he would never perform
the song imagine
in public out of respect to his father
he said the only time he would ever
perform imagine in public was if the
world were ending and now julian
believes that the world is ending and so
as a part of a solidarity event for
ukraine julian lennon performed imagine
which really made me wonder
hasn't ukraine suffered enough do you
really have to add insult to injury the
country is beleaguered by war you've got
the russian army invading and then on
top the cherry on top is that julian
lennon has to sing maybe the single
stupidest song ever written that that is
so ironic actually the way that he's
he's doing it because
the song
the song is as pro-russia as it could be
this song is as anti-ukraine as you can
get i have i have the lyrics here
we all know it's a kind of communist
anthem
i'd imagine there's no heaven it's easy
if you try no hell below us above us
only sky imagine all the people living
for today
that's what people in war-torn countries
want to hear people whose families have
just been slaughtered by an invading
army they want to say there's no heaven
you're never going to see them again
they're turning to worm food any hope
you might have that's gone imagine
there's no countries it isn't hard to do
yeah putin's imagining there's no
countries that's why he's rolling his
tanks into ukraine right now the
ukrainians are are praying that there
will be countries that people will
respect borders
and this isn't the first time russia's
invaded ukraine don't when this when
this song was written russia was
dominating ukraine through the soviet
empire after it gobbled up a lot of
other countries nothing to kill or die
for and no religion too yeah there's no
religion too you've got ukrainian
catholics praying for a peaceful end to
this and then you've got a former kgb
agent from the most officially atheistic
regime in the history of the world
rolling the tanks in but imagine imagine
all that living life and peace that's
not usually what happens when we've got
those kinds of regimes you may say i'm a
dreamer but i'm not the only one i hope
someday you'll join us in the world will
be as one what are we going to be is one
under what under what kind of government
under this atheist communist government
and when i say communist government i
mean that
specifically because verse 3 is imagine
no possessions i wonder if you can
no no need for greed or hunger or
brotherhood of man
putin's imagining no possessions no
ukrainians you don't have the right to
possess your country the soviet union in
which putin was steeped and raised they
imagined no possessions they took
possessions away from people they
nationalized everything they stole those
goods
and rather than having wealth and
prosperity and a brotherhood of man what
did that result in poverty and misery
for everyone
imagine all the people sharing all the
world well
everyone gets to share but equally but
some people get to share more equally
than others you may say i'm a dreamer
but i'm not the only one i hope someday
you'll join us the world will live as
one i am so sorry
to the ukrainian people that
while they've got this open wound from
russia invading this misguided hippie
has rubbed salt in that wound by playing
this awful song which
lyrically ideologically is just so
terrible exactly the wrong message as is
often the case the people who sing this
song as though it were some virtuous
moral anthem are actually
presenting some of the ideas that are
the least moral in the world but it's
also just unbearable to listen to it we
used to have good hymnity in in our
civilization beautiful songs and hymns
and gregorian chants and full masses and
now we just sing hippy ditties from the
70s and 80s as though that were the most
inspiring thing in the world is it any
wonder that people are more depressed
now
when we want to actually focus our hope
in our efforts one great way to do it
would be 40 days for life our culture
screams follow the science and then
ignores the science
nowhere is this clearer than on abortion
the science is clear babies are human
babies are alive that's true when
they're out of the womb that's true when
they're in the womb and it is wrong
to kill them when they're in the room
this is why the pro-life movement is
winning right now okay we focus on the
facts and the logic and the mind in the
abortion debate
we also focus on the heart we also focus
on what this means to you okay and
that's why our friends at 40 days for
life have written the number two amazon
christian bestseller what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change minds and convert
hearts in a brave new world 40 days for
life is based in texas it's one of the
largest pro-life grassroots
organizations in the world they've got 1
million volunteers in 1 000 cities
holding peaceful 40-day vigils outside
of abortion facilities to save lives and
help abortion workers leave their jobs
get the book what to say when today it
covers the old arguments and the new
ones so get it and check out
40daysforlife.com to help end abortion
wherever you live
speaking of
world hunger
there will be no no hunger nothing to
live or die for speaking of
political morality
i was at yale yesterday was it yesterday
or two two days ago i was at yale and i
was doing an event with senator cruz we
were doing a verdict event and we always
do the q a lines and it was actually a
wonderful event and it despite all the
threats of protests and boycotts and all
sorts of things
the students in the room were terrific
about a third of the students in the
room were liberals even the liberal
student newspaper was very nice to us
about the event we did get one question
though that was a little bit out of left
field i will let that student present it
himself
assuming that would end global hunger
would you fellate another man
if it would end world hunger would you
fellate another man
really playing into stereotype over
there at yale they're on there on the
sexual front on the moral front so uh
the kid obviously meant this as a joke i
think it was clear he meant this as a
joke but there actually is a
straightforward answer to it
i made a joke that i don't think landed
in the moment which is that this shows
the moral idiocy of so many liberal
campuses now because what what
students are being taught what a lot of
people believe on the lib side is
something called consequentialist ethics
and consequentialist ethics in layman's
terms is just the idea that the ends
justify the means that if you've got
some good end in mind that you can
commit any sort of immoral stuff in the
in the middle and then that's
as long as something good results in the
end then it justifies all the immoral
stuff you've done in the meantime the
this is the idea that stalin is said to
have believed that you can't make an
omelette without cracking a few eggs
okay yeah we're gonna have to kill
millions of people but in the end we're
going to have utopia and
as as a practical matter that doesn't
happen you you don't you don't actually
solve world hunger by
in this young man's words fellating
another man but even if you could it
wouldn't justify the immoral action in
the middle and so i made a joke about
what's called deontological ethics which
is that you should choose whether i
can't believe a joke about deontological
ethics didn't land but what that means
is that
the the the morality of the act should
be judged by the act itself not by
whatever
wonderful ends you imagine it could
result in and
what's funny about this stupid question
that this kid asked is it actually does
get to the moral divide on the left and
the right
and it's probably the clearest moral
divide which is
should we should we say for instance
that the the liberation of women such as
it is
uh justifies killing a baby
men and women can't be equal
unless women are allowed to kill their
babies because men can't get pregnant so
that's a huge difference so if women are
saddled with the perils of pregnancy
then and the burden of pregnancy then
they can't be equal so therefore women
need to abort their kids that's the
argument for legal abortion
ironically
you don't even get the liberation in the
end you don't even get the good ends
but you really what you get is just
depression and despair and a terrible
culture but even if you could get the
good ends it wouldn't
justify that
and then media i deliberate not just
mediate but a number of places in the
liberal media decided to make fun of me
for saying that i would not
fellate a man to to end world hunger
they they said knowles went on to accuse
the student of attempting to justify
flagrantly immoral behavior to achieve a
good end adding i tell you my friend the
ends do not justify the means absolutely
absolutely not the host did not expand
on why he believes performing fellatio
is flagrantly immoral so they're making
fun of me
mediaite is mocking me
a
married catholic man
for refusing to perform fellatio
can you imagine what kind of upside-down
world we are in humor must be dead irony
must be dead
mediaite cannot understand cannot
possibly imagine
why a married catholic man might object
to performing
fellatio and i think they're sincere
they're trying to mock me here but i
don't think they're they're being ironic
in their line i think they actually have
no idea why someone might object to this
the act itself which uh you know no
don't don't do it uh or the
the idea that that act would be
justified to solve world hunger
uh no we need i something has gone
seriously wrong and we talk about how
sexual education is really really bad
these days
the the this is why we have
anti-grooming laws now in florida and
other states soon to see
uh clearly this has been going on for a
lot longer mediai good grief
read a book about morality read up on
your catechism or something goodness
gracious
you actually saw this
uh
similar kind of uh confusion in the most
important national news story that would
be the saga of will and jada smith
after the slap heard around the world
there was a video that came out of jada
smith humiliating her husband again
so will
you know stan perella is coming to the
table she's going to be at the red table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and i redefining our relationship
i would say don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness if you
confess there come help us again please
i'm still dealing with foolishness don't
no no she yeah because she don't just
would you say that she helped us heal
the hurts that we cause between one
another my social media presence is my
bread and butter okay so you can't just
use me for social media and not
you know don't just start bro i'm
standing in my house
don't just start rolling
please watch a stare at the red table
because she's helped us a lot can't you
tell
a lot of people were responding this and
saying will blink three times if if
you're being held captive will poor will
and this is obviously abusive behavior
but i can't join the pity party for will
smith
will
husband your wife husband is a
noun and it's a verb too
have some
spine have some leadership here
if your wife is filming you
against your will you a movie star whose
brand is really important whose public
image is really important then say no no
more phone honey sorry you don't get the
phone anymore because you are abusing
this and me and our marriage and this is
really really bad
and so no you don't no no more twitter
today jada sorry
you're not i don't think you're allowed
to say this anymore because this is very
patriarchal and old-fashioned and
terrible what's the alternative
what's before the liberals criticize me
before media matters cuts this clip
they're probably already doing it
because i had the audacity to say that
will smith should lead his household and
jada smith should should maybe put down
the phone and listen
what's the alternative
do you think the will smith the current
marriage is that's the better option
that that
this wife
is publicly humiliating and cuckolding
her husband all the time and the guy is
so broken down about this that he has he
has a nervous breakdown at the oscars
and slaps wil cr chris rock rather
across the face
and still seems cowed and and timid and
is that
that's the option and you've got all
sort of disorder in your family
or maybe will stands up and says no you
can't no you know jada you're not
allowed to sleep with other people
no jada you're not allowed to publicly
humiliate me by talking about sleeping
with other people on air no you're not
allowed to just use me to promote your
own stupid show that nobody is watching
the only reason we ever hear about is
because she pulls stunts like this
no
no more you're go i'm head of this
household and i'm going to be the
knuckle dragging troglodyte patriarch to
say stop
cuckolding me on television
stop it what's the alter give me a
better alternative and i'm willing to
hear it feminists liberals progressives
but until i hear it
i i'm gonna stick with the old-fashioned
idea jada on this stupid show that we
only ever hear about because of these
exact kind of stunts she just came out
and and explained her theory of men and
women and feminism in the creepiest way
and actually in a way that totally
proves the conservatives right on these
anti-grooming laws jada smith says that
she was taught to
to pleasure herself sex with someone you
love as woody allen called it
went by her own grandmother when she was
nine years old and the creepiest part i
think
is the reasoning behind it
my grandmother
taught me
about self-pleasuring because she wanted
me to know that that pleasure was from
me exactly she didn't want me to fall
into the hands of a man and if he gave
me pleasure to think that that was him
and she taught me at nine
so creepy and this is what jada smith is
teaching her kids so this is going on
and on
that this
anti-male hatred
this woman and her grandmother i guess
hated men so much
that they wanted to divorce even sexual
pleasure
from the other sex the the
clearest example of where you are
supposed to take pleasure in
the other sex in men or if you're a man
and women to take even that away because
i don't need a man because a woman needs
a man like a fish needs a bicycle i
guess that's the logical conclusion of
feminism i actually i i don't think that
jada or her grandmother have gone off
the rails
if they're beginning from their crazy
flawed feminist premises
but the premises are nuts they're wrong
they're going to lead to misery they're
going to lead to bad marriages and bad
societies so
fine liberals feminists you don't like
my traditional view of things
what's the alter do you really think
that that's any better a grandma
teaching her nine-year-old daughter to
hate men so much that she's got to
keep everything just to herself and then
that being passed on through the
generate you think that's good that's
going to lead to an ordered marriage
what is
what's your alternative to the tried and
true tradition
speaking of putting a little bit of
faith in yourself when you want to set
up your own future in a ordered and
normal and smart and prudent way i would
strongly recommend you check out bank on
yourself right now go to
bankonyourself.com
knowles we have been brainwashed into
believing that the only way to grow our
money for retirement is to risk it in
the stock market but that's not true you
can reach your financial goals and
dreams without taking unnecessary risks
bank on yourself is a better way to grow
and protect your hard-earned money this
retirement plan alternative has never
had a losing year in over 160 years you
can get access to your money for any
purpose no questions asked you can even
use it for purchases or opportunities
without interrupting the growth of those
dollars this is the strategy famous
businesses used when no banker would
lend them a dime and almost anyone can
do it there's no volatility you are in
control you get peace of mind this is
the most important part of it i think
you will know the minimum guaranteed
value of your plan on the day that you
tap into it and at every point along the
way get your free report with all the
details of how adding bank on yourself
to your financial plan can help you take
back control of your money today do it
at bank on yourself dot com slash
knowles bank on yourself dot com slash
knowles this information is for
educational purposes only and it's not a
solicitation for the purchase of any
financial product all guarantees are
based on the claims paying ability of
the insurer there is no question
leftism in this country is spreading
like a disease it's getting clearer and
clearer by the day
i think people are really waking up to
this now because trancing the kids was
the final straw and we just think
however we got here we got to stop it we
got to undo whatever led us to this
moment that's why we are discussing it
all on a very special episode of
backstage tonight not only will all your
favorite daily wire host be there me but
i'll also be joined by jeremy and ben
and matt and drew and everybody else so
we're going to be talking about the
state of our country and we're going to
be welcoming
a special guest that's why you all have
to tune in check it out backstage
tonight
all of your favorite dw peeps at 7 pm
eastern 6 p.m central dailywire.com and
on our youtube channel the daily wire
youtube channel if you're not a member
yet time's running out so go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code build the future
for 45
off four or five percent off the offer
ends tomorrow do not miss out we'll be
right back with a lot more
the feminism that jada smith and so many
other people are espousing has been
building up for a long time and it isn't
good and it's pretty incoherent but but
now i think it's become
totally incoherent i think now the
contradictions of feminism are
undeniable
cracker jacks you know the candy you eat
when you're at the ballpark cracker
jacks has just engaged in this feminist
virtue signaling campaign to to say
we're actually woke we the old-timey
baseball popcorn we're very woke we're
no longer cracker jack
we're cracker jill
[Music]
we're adding our face to the game
and we'll run
[Music]
play ball
play ball
play ball girl power we we're adding our
face to the game now except we're
singing this song 40 years too late
because what's going on right now is not
that women are being added to sporting
events it's that women are being
completely taken out of sporting events
because now transgenderism is the latest
craze and so men are going into the
girls sports and they're beating all the
girls because men are physically
stronger so actually no more women
pretty short-lived run for cracker jill
guess we're back to cracker jacks aren't
we
aren't we a little bit late guys you're
you were you're one or two
woke social movements behind from what
we're actually doing right now even that
that first rhyme
buy me some peanuts and cracker jill
nothing can stop you if you have the
will
i'm not saying that some great genius
philosopher wrote this song but it it
does sum up the current view of the left
which is that everything in life is
about your will
it's not about reason it's not about
intellect it's not about reality
it's that if you if you have a
sufficient tyranny of the will that you
that you are willing to enforce on
everyone else then nothing can stop you
and that's just not true
there are there are boys out there who
have a very strong will to be women
and they're trying to force that onto
everyone but but it's not it's not true
it's not real there is a limit boys
can't be girls to use the the
most timely example
girls might have the will to beat men at
the swimming contest but they can't do
it generally speaking they can't do it
occasionally i guess there are some
flukes and but generally speaking it's
the big hulking dude wearing the borat
suit he's going to be the one to beat
the girls because will is not enough we
also we have to bring our will
and
especially our base desires and our
appetites we have to bring that lower
will in particular
into accord with reason
and reality
and facts and logic speaking of facts
and logic ben
ben was out at some university campus a
couple nights ago
and and ben
as usual was asked a really dumb
question
by a student in the crowd take a listen
to the question
i'm a mathematician and a physicist here
a double major and i also just won the
most prestigious award in the country to
pursue research at any institution i
want the national science foundation
graduate research fellowship so i think
i'm pretty you know qualified to say
that most of what you're saying is based
on like old data um but my question to
you and so
i realized last month right sure um like
for example gender identity disorder
that's the dsm-4 bro we use the dsm-5
now for psychologists to be able to talk
i literally cited the dsm-5 in the
speech and it's called gender dysphoria
which is literally that i use throughout
the speech not gender you sound like a
boso
and you can't even make your wife bro so
what's good
so this kid comes out and he says
i'm a mathematician and a physicist
i'm a mathematician i've won the most
prestigious award i've won he's what
he's talking about is the nsf grant
which is this government grand that i
don't know the prestige is a little in
question as far as i'm concerned
i know some people who have won the
grant and they're not generally speaking
they're not the brightest bulbs in the
pack but but even
even beyond my own personal experience
of knowing people who've gotten this
grant
the very fact that this dummy won it is
evidence that it's not a very
prestigious award
this student whatever he is
mathematician or physicist or whatever
he's pretending to be he is obviously
not intelligent and he's
most obviously not educated
he he doesn't speak well he doesn't
think very well and the best
comeback he can think up to ben shapiro
who is contradicting his fantasies is
you're a bozo bro and you you don't get
any girls i'm going to clean up his
language you don't you don't even get
girls bro you don't even screw girls and
you your wife doesn't find you sexually
attractive
and this kid is as confident as they get
and and he's even got a credential he's
got a credential of something that
perhaps at one time had some prestige so
it is it any wonder that the the country
is in such bad shape
i always go back to that donald rumsfeld
idea that there were known knowns
known unknowns and unknown unknowns
meaning there's things we know that we
know there are things that we know that
we don't know so we lack knowledge but
we're at least aware of it and then the
most dangerous thing is the unknown
unknowns the things that we don't know
that we don't know
very often it is the absolute stupidest
people on earth who are the most
convinced of their own genius
socrates on the other hand one of the
smartest people to have ever lived is
the man who said i know that i know
nothing
and that was his great genius saint
thomas aquinas another one of the most
intelligent people ever to have lived
had a religious vision he said
everything i've written is so much straw
thomas aquinas wrote the summa theologia
the sum of all
the sum of all theological knowledge and
he said oh yeah that's all just straw i
want to burn it i don't want it and then
you have this know-nothing this kid who
has maybe two brain cells to rub
together comes out and he says i'm a
mathematician i'm a physicist and that's
why boys or girls or whatever
it's sad it's depressing it's always fun
to watch these college i mean look i go
out and do them so i've had the first
hand joy and and pleasure of this as
well but it's always fun to watch clips
of someone just destroy some liberal
student with facts and logic but it's
pretty depressing too because these kids
often have fairly prestigious degrees
and they sometimes get awards for
whatever reason and
they have the confidence to run the
country and they're running the country
into the ground what are they being
taught i know what they're being taught
at middleton cross plains area school
district
in wisconsin
they're not learning their abcs they're
learning their lgbs not a whole lot of
reading writing and arithmetic at that
school no students during school hours
are being
brought into an auditorium
to watch a teacher put on a drag show
[Applause]
[Music]
this
fella is dancing on stage
uh you're so lucky if you're listening
to this right now and you're not
watching it
it's a fella who i guess is a teacher
who's dancing around in a skimpy outfit
showing his derriere and he's got
some kind of stiletto heels on
and
i think the saddest part of it all is
not his own confusion it's that the
students aren't into it so he's he's out
there dancing his heart away and the
students
it's not even that they're booing him or
heckling him the saddest part is that
they're kind of just timidly
sadly applauding oh huh
yeah okay good job mr smith or whatever
good job mr so-and-so
this is of course brought to us by libs
of tick tock one of the greatest twitter
accounts out there
the kids are being male educated here
they're being taught things that aren't
true like that boys can be girls or that
it's good to dress up and drag during
school hours and dance around
but there's something even
maybe even sadder or at least equally
sad is the wasted time
sometimes you you go back
i'll go back and read letters
that people wrote sometimes famous
people sometimes just ordinary people
that they wrote during high school or
during college sometimes these are
published with collections of their
letters and what strikes you is how
intelligent they are how articulate they
are what kinds of stories and knowledge
people just had offhand you'll sometimes
hear about farmers in the 19th century
just being able to quote the bible from
the king james bible just being able to
quote it from memory people can't do
that now even the really smart kids even
the geniuses with who are mathematicians
and physicists who won the very very
real nsf award grant right all of these
they don't know anything even at the
prestigious universities they often
don't know anything
and it's so sad because of all the
wasted time i forget who the poet was
there's some modern poet who had a
surprisingly good poem for modern poetry
that said that the sad thing about sin
is not only how sin hurts people and
destroys things and hurts ourselves and
damages our relationship with god
but that it's just such a damn waste of
time that you could be you've got
precious few moments on this earth that
you could be using to build something up
to do something productive to to pursue
virtue to make your life better and your
life better for your families and then
when we sin we just waste time and for
what so that we can do some drugs or
like do some weird sex thing or dance
around or have to watch some in this
case have to watch some teacher
humiliate himself on stage and pretend
this is good it's just such a waste of
time and it's a real attack on students
education
speaking of attacks
there was a major physical
violent attack yesterday in new york in
the subway system
the
the information about this attack
was really muddy and really vague the
good news is
that though a gunman walked into a
subway car had gas canisters had gas
masks had guns apparently fired lots of
rounds
only 10 people were shot
and apparently last time i checked the
news on this before the show
no one had died some people were in
critical condition but it was stable
a couple dozen more were injured just
from
people trampling them or from smoke
inhalation or getting off but
this was a major attack
and there's a rule i think maybe it was
ann coulter who came up with this rule
at least she's popularized it
when
when you do not immediately hear about a
suspect's race or sex or religion
you can know with 100 certainty that the
suspect is not a straight white
christian man
you can just you can know that because
if there's even a chance that the
suspect who's committed the crime
is a straight white christian man that
will be the first thing in the headlines
and frankly even if if the guy who
is is the perpetrator here or the
suspect isn't white but is plausibly
maybe there's a chance he's white
and a man and straight and christian
you'll see that in the headlines you saw
this notably in the killing of trayvon
martin they said white man kills black
teenager in this neighborhood and he
wasn't a white man george zimmerman's a
hispanic guy and then the new york times
said well he know he's a white hispanic
guy looks like a hispanic hispanic guy
to me they just got excited because they
saw a name that seemed seemed white they
saw he said man and so they ran with the
headline
and so the minute i saw we don't know
who the suspect is we don't know it i
said okay well it's not a straight white
christian man i can know that not
because i know anything really about
crime or justice it's just because i
know the media so well and it turns out
that that's right they've finally named
a person of interest
frank james
still wasn't seeing a ton of information
about him and so frank james is
a 62-year-old black guy
who has expressed radical
racial political views on the internet
here's just one clip that's going around
i had no idea with that african name
that she would be married to
a white man one of my subscribers
brought that to my attention
yeah
our black sister supreme court justice
power to the people is very
white
i don't believe
oh god
wait a minute
this this is the [ __ ] right
there yet
there he is with
white man
black sister
kentucky [ __ ]
married to a
can you believe that that awful woman
married to a white man
this guy i think is nuts i watched some
of his other videos and generally
speaking they are not presenting a
coherent political ideology generally
speaking he just seems like a crazy
person and but but he does express some
views on his politics and what he's
expressing is
clearly a black nationalist anti-white
kind of political ideology
i don't even want to say it
i don't do i have to i guess i have to
say it
if the shoe were on the other foot can
you imagine what the media would say i
have to say it just to get just to get
it out there
if
there were a similarly crazy white guy
who said all sorts of crazy things but
then also said i hate it when white guys
marry black women isn't that horrible
that's terrible to the white race
every single headline would be the white
supremacy is a terrible problem in
america we all the white people are so
awful and the and uh we have got too
much whiteness and we got to abolish
whiteness and
but you're not going to hear any of that
the absence of that kind of talk here
which i think frankly might even be
merited because i assume the guy
actually is just nuts i don't i don't
know that this is the terror attack of
some political revolutionary genius i
think it's probably a pretty pretty
mentally disturbed guy who also has
pretty disturbed racial and political
views
but the absence the absolute absence of
talk about this of the black nationalism
of the anti-white bigotry
the absence is the indictment and it's
not even the indictment of this guy it's
the indictment of the legacy
establishment liberal media
speaking of physical violence on racial
rounds for that matter
a yaf speaker was just
had to just be escorted out of a speech
at the university of buffalo
by the police the yaf chairman
this young student
called the police while cowering in the
bathroom from the violent mob the
violent mob was made up of blm members
blm members who showed up to the
university of buffalo and didn't just
politely ask their questions but we're
threatening people we're getting very
very violent we're banging very heavily
on the doors and the funniest part of
all
you who the speaker was
alan west
not not a white supremacist last time i
checked alan west very much a black man
who has very mainstream conservative
political views he was giving a talk on
how america is not a racist country this
was too much for blm so they chased all
these people off campus and and what
what they believe what the leftist at
you buffalo and blm specifically
believes is that if they make enough of
these threats and they have enough
people escorted out by police and they
have enough students cowering in the
bathroom calling 9-1-1 that
conservatives are going to stop showing
up to campus
and so yeah they'll get they'll get in
trouble maybe some of them will get in
trouble actually probably probably they
won't given the left-wing leadings of
the universities but hey they'll achieve
what they wanted which is to kick
conservatives off campus sort of immoral
means but they're going to get that end
that they really want so they think it's
all justified i am scheduled to speak at
the university of buffalo
in two weeks i believe
and
i suspect they think that they're going
to get my speech shut down because oh we
don't want to hear it probably the
university administration doesn't want
to have to deal with this probably
there's going to be a lot more security
costs
and they think that we're just going to
say okay we're not going to do it maybe
we'll go next semester
but you know me you know i'm i'm not
going to give in that easily so i will
be going to university of buffalo i
can't wait to give my talk on yaf i
think i'm going to focus in particular
on how blm is a criminal organization
and how we're not going to put up with
that we're not going to be bullied and
we're not going to back down and we're
not going to let the radical left take
over our entire country
because we don't want them
to chase us or threaten us with physical
violence so i'm going to go there and i
think i think maybe they just gave me my
topic for the speech i very much look
forward to that if you're in the buffalo
area i sure hope you come out you can
find out more at yaf.org sign up get
some tickets it's gonna be a lot of fun
it's gonna be a lot of fun they're not
they're not gonna take away our fun i
don't think so speaking of violence
there's some good news on the violence
front
which is that oklahoma has just outlawed
probably
the most vile and evil form of violence
in the entire country which is abortion
oklahoma has just made it a felony to
perform an abortion
the governor of oklahoma signed state
legislation yesterday making that a
felony it's the senate bill 612
which says quote a person shall not
purposely perform or attempt to perform
an abortion except to save the life of a
pregnant woman in a medical emergency so
not even an
emotional emergency or a psychological
emergency where the woman might be
distressed no we're talking about an
acute medical emergency which
practically speaking doesn't exist
there's
there there is no case in which the
abortion specifically is the cure
and is the only cure for a
medical threat to the life of the mother
we can get to more of that perhaps some
other time we do a fuller abortion day
but anyone convicted of this of
performing abortion
shall be guilty of a felony punishable
by a fine of a hundred thousand dollars
not to exceed a hundred thousand dollars
or by confinement in prison for a term
not to exceed 10 years or by such fi
fine and imprisonment together this is
great stuff it'll be challenged by the
courts but actually probably there won't
be time for it to make it all the way up
to the high court because the supreme
court is going to decide
this spring
whether or not to overrule roe vs wade
and planned parenthood v casey that is
the supreme court this spring could very
possibly overturn the fictional right
constitutional right to an abortion that
a bunch of robed lawyers on the supreme
court made up out of whole cloth in
1973. i was just talking to senator cruz
about this a couple days ago and we were
doing our event at yale he is
he's a supreme court litigator he's
argued before the court he was up for a
supreme court nomination though he
turned it down
he knows the institution well he clerked
for the chief justice he thinks it's
quite likely that the supreme court will
overrule roe versus wade in which case
laws like this are going to be really
really important we should see them all
around the country
starting now
why did the governor sign this bill
knowing that it very likely could be
overturned depending on what the court
does with row because he said he's going
to sign every piece of pro-life
legislation that comes before his desk i
love that
great job for the governor of oklahoma
keep it simple it's not that complicated
killing babies is really really really
wrong any law that comes before the
governor that will
stop that from happening or reduce the
frequency
at which that happens
sign it love that speaking of healthcare
before we go have to get to this story
a new covid variant just dropped here it
goes guys you you were you were all
waiting around on that last covid sub
variant that was the covid omicron ba2
sub-variant well now we got the covid
omicron xe
this is this is the latest this is like
the latest iphone version where it's not
you know it's not all that different but
they try to really hype it up and they
are really trying to hype it up the
kovidzar is saying that we might we
might need to get back to those public
health measures to stop the spread of
the covid
xe omicron ba lmnop
does that mean that extending the mass
mandate in public transportation is a
live option it's on the table
yeah i i look this is a cdc decision uh
and i think it is absolutely on the
table and and dr wolenski is going to
make her decision based on on the
framework that the cdc scientists create
and and we'll make a decision uh
collectively based on that absolutely
absolutely it's still on the table i
hate to say i told you so it ties right
into my favorite comment at the top of
the show i told you fouchy's not going
away the public health coveted apparatus
is not going away they never gave up
that power and they're gonna bring it
back when they're in political trouble
are they in political trouble you better
believe it
everything is going wrong for the ruling
class in this country right now there is
no sign that any of it is going to turn
around before the midterm elections
they know it's going to be bad they're
not going to get that drop out of the
sky of good luck because they've made
their own
bad luck and you can't just unwind that
out of the blue so what can you expect
you can expect more lockdowns what can
you expect you can expect certainly more
mail-in ballots you can expect them to
tighten up on that power
because
every decision they've made to this
point
this has left them
their their only option if they want to
try to stop the the flood in november so
get get ready for it folks get ready for
c
xcab
two one two three variant or we can
wield our political power and say no
enough i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john vickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire